Historically, I have had occasional cold source, usually following times of stress.
Since starting the Joe Tippen's protocol, nearly two years ago, however, I have had nearly
constant battle with cold source.
One of them follows another.
I'm using the rife, I present for cold source, which has been very helpful except for
one incredibly powerful outbreak that covered half of my lower lip line.
I'm wondering if you think there could be a connection between these crazy, constant
outbreaks and the Joe Tippen's protocol.
Could these so cold source be some kind of a herx reaction?
Well, I do not think that there are herx reactions, so first of all, you have to understand what
cold source are.
Cold source are a herpes simplex virus that lives in the ganglion of the nerve, so viruses
are very difficult to kill.
Some people have believed that they're not even living things that can be killed, so it
is for certain that they are extremely difficult to kill.
All that I've had cold source, if I have cold source in your mouth, that's an outbreak
of that virus that comes down the nerve ganglion.
Typically, the virus lives in the trigeminal nerve ganglion, which is up by your jaw joint.
That's your fifth cranial nerve, and then opportunistically, it can come down that nerve and then
expose as a lesion in your mouth or on your lips.
That's the opportunistic reason why they come out.
What you stated right here, and it can come out in times of stress.
Why is that?
Well, it's typically believed that anything that can change the pH of your mouth drastically
can cause this opportunity for the herpes simplex virus to come out.
That's why if you sucked on a lemon, people say, oh, I sucked on a lemon and I got a cold
sore or I drank a bunch of lemon juice and I started getting cold sore breakouts because
you changed the pH of your mouth.
Well, under stress, that changes the pH of your mouth.
Could it be a herx reaction that's causing this to come out?
No, because the definition of a herx reaction is when toxins that is endotoxins that are created
from die-off of cells, typically a herx reaction is from die-off bacteria in your body, that
overwhelms the detoxification pathways.
That means endotoxins, it's parts of the bacteria, organism itself as it explodes and bursts
apart through the cell lysis, you're killing that bacteria.
It has to detox out of your body.
It can overwhelm your liver, detox pathways and you can feel malaise and feel icky.
It's definitely not that.
I don't know any drugs, so first of all, let's take a step back.
What is the Jotipins protocol?
Jotipins protocols are using Fenn-Bendazol.
So can Fenn-Bendazol cause a change in the pH of your mouth?
I don't know.
I looked up some, tried to find some data on that and there is none.
So certainly any drug can do have also some crazy effects on different people.
I would say, if you narrowed it down to, okay, it all started when I started the Jotipins
protocol, I'm pretty hard to make a big argument about that unless something else changed in
your life at that time, and I would certainly say that any type of medication could have
that effect on you, so the only way to absolutely know for sure is to go off of it for a period
of time.
And there would be anything wrong with pulsed it, maybe go off for two weeks, see if that
clears things up and wow, that really clears things up and maybe you can go back on that
again.
So that's what I would think, and that's what I would suggest if the pulsars are driving
you crazy.